just talk to any public company
executive it's a big open secret
you know publicly they they're all
shareholder driven privately they'll
tell you they freaking hate it
and it's and you know they're they're
literally there's massive pressure
massive pressure not to mention lopsided
incentive structures because you know
paid paid inequity um
to
as they all know i mean it's not a
secret make decisions that they know are
bad for their company and avoid making
decisions that they know are good for
their company so they can help some 29
year old analysts get their bonus
um you know uh they're you know they're
remember you know steve jobs ignored
wall street never paid dividends didn't
care if you like us invested this if you
don't like us don't invest this was his
attitude and the joke is if you're doing
well they're going to invest in you
anyway because they're gamblers not
investors
um the short-termers anyway you have
long-term investors who believe in the
leadership team you have long-term
investors who believe in your vision and
they stick with you thick and thin and
when you have a hard time they don't
just suddenly abandon you those are the
ones we should focus on um because they
actually obey your values
the good news is
there's a new breed of young leader and
there's you know some of the newer ipos
your airbnbs your sweet greens
that i that are talking more about the
infinite game they're talking more about
things like triple bottom lines they're
talking more about purpose and you know
i i hope that they're able to withstand
the overwhelming pressures that i didn't
i don't even think they knew how much
pressure it would be
um uh one of my favorite ceos is a guy
by the name of gary ridge who's the ceo
of wt40 as in the lubricant company and
he was on one of his analysts calls
and the analyst said you know gary
you missed your numbers
and gary said
no
my numbers are fine i missed journalists
um
and and i and i and i think that if we
have that kind of courage
if the leaders have that kind of courage
to run the business they the way that
they think it should be run and
literally say invest in this or don't
you know um then i then i think wall
street is is less dangerous but they
wall street has exerted a lopsided an
unbalanced amount of negative pressure
in companies so far too long